the other being a couch potato could
actually be part of your genetic makeup
yeah it seems like everything
is decided by our genetic make up these
days researchers at Aberdeen University
work with colleagues and China and they
did a study with
ASAP science and they found out and
that's pretty much the case
but they look sign to studying myself an
interesting genetic connection
after separating mice into two groups
those that chose to run on there will
more often and those that decided not to
run as much
the difference was clear in their
offspring after ten generations
the running mice were run on their
wheels 75 percent more often than the
other group
and by 16 generations they were running
seven miles a day
as opposed to the average for miles it
seen their motivation for physical
activity
with genetic alright is everything
genetic
we like to think that it's not we
control our they in our destiny but at
the end of the day
is the primordial who's controlling
everything we're doing
did you guys react to this video the
same way I did which was like
mice runs seven-mile
yeah I think like a lot she insists that
the latter at it but i mean the Cape
think up a tiny little anxious I don't
so believable
I'm so I was a question about broadway
aloof that is a good question that would
be the equivalent
how many miles for human would be seven
mouth about 10,000 we could not be
rather busy
me that's what they're doing they don't
have a lot else to do yet they're not
working
we're still very babbling about god
knows what theyre they're out there like
protease
less like that was mean to me being a
morning person and a night person
right so that that maybe that like that
I'm a night person tolley I kick it
somewhere around
in night I get a little energy in me
knack replace a mostly creativity
happens at night
for I was reading thing and that gives a
shit that calm and
at but that yeah I i adeptly think that
it's in your makeup BC
back families you know yeah it's it's
it's it is genetic I think and
so how much do you guys think we control
how much do you think is actually one
with anywhere using the Internet
less than you think because I read all
these books on about our attraction
to to each other the explicit sexual
attraction and 99 percent if it is
unconscious you think you're making a
choice you think well I like this and
that you don't fuckin know what you like
because it's all happening unconsciously
like they
realize that man that that's the hip to
waist ratio that makes a woman
attractive to amend or not not options
batter skinny or whatever
it's all these weird things that go into
it so that some sane
eat more than you think your gender your
controlled genetically
later that video there's a great thing
about the %uh the couch potato gene
literally that your that there is a gene
that your left you're more likely to
stage that they're not just that you
generationally learn to work out but
there's something in you that makes you
want to stay
and fit you have to overcome that I mean
I I literally feel like I have it is a
very hard for me to motivate
in a way that i think is beyond the
normal
human characteristic of what he said
around like I I have worked out in four
years
and now I can put the blame my parents
this is fantastic
that but like you have to have been a
pro this order
the at the be the three others bony at
the end like a bit a lot of this is by
men on so you have to overcome that
yeah I'll and but I need a pill to
overcome that right so you couldn't do
it that's at the bar that I find
fascinating that the part that you want
to sit there and I'm with you I could
watch basketball day on a sunday and not
move but at the same point I could go to
the gym and run around and being right
but this is heavy but you don't have
that I don't think I can overcome it
and I get now that thing that we saw in
the first part I don't get
this rush from work it out I don't I
like I get a rush from competition
I'll try and win things or lose things
but I like to be involved in some ways
course cap but I don't get like when I
run
I don't come back I'm not like or old
man what a rush
little if they don't have that all you
got a competitive merit on a more
competitive sleeper
that's right writer I want to be like an
Olympic sleep that might get a pillowtop
regarded to jump into that you gotta
have some disparity
what are you able to overcome your your
genetic predispositions I really like to
say i i got a call
I got a challenge the veracity a ban
statement that he has worked on for you
to tell me that you haven't lifted
get some like that I as I believe it so
a headache
really that's natural yeah I'd read
article 8 I'll no it doesn't do drugs
you know you're not using nope nope not
at all juicing and not working out which
is an odd thing to do
um I've never you know I was always that
active guy worked out all the time so
I don't anymore but that has to do with
Mike its
I yep definitely abt only you more
control that's why
you know they say the journey of life is
to be coming just aware becoming awake
because we walk to like to sleep
tried over the years like we learned
that exertion any eggs are good
there right right turns out they're good
but it you know for years in the
seventies they don't donate
you know too much red meat and now maybe
with maybe maybe it's okay certainly for
certain people and protein is definitely
good
and so this bill good certain drugs are
good on drugs are bad coffee turns out
good
like you know a point great really good
for you know so but one thing that has
never changed my doctor said it's only
if you put in this project perspective
he's like
exercise they knew it then they know it
now
it helps by add years to your life you
know I have a daughter
I want to stay healthy and I have this
sense the even that
is not going to do it for me that's and
I think that there's a predisposition
not a crazy person don't you give a
sport you enjoy deeply battle all the
way back while playing softball I love
playing things to keep score
it's just hard to get older hard to find
yes six other guys to get together give
you are playing baseball so much that he
wait he plays every Sunday
I've played for a year and happen every
Sunday never been there
I got injured like three years ago when
I had only bettered why I injury I got
an injury took me out so you have my
backside on play more but
I'd like to I miss it I'm better than
you guys i bad note get up of your fat
ass
do some exercise you can watch this
while you're on the treadmill that's
where I do most my internet